so we're here in DC you're such a busy
woman but you took time out of your
schedule to be here for history talks
what is it about this event that you
said I gotta be there yeah I heard
Bradley Cooper was going to be here
I have a lot of family in DC but of
course and I love history and Serena and
I have been fortunate to be a part of it
so I love that a e brings people
together history brings people together
and telling stories is really what life
is about you know when you think about
your history and the impact that you've
made on on women on Sports on culture
what do you hope people most remember at
the end of the day by the end of the day
that I was a good person you know that's
the most important thing and then if you
can be part of something bigger than
your own life that means helping others
that's what really matters I have to
tell you watching you at the U.S open
the whole world was there we were
cheering for you did you feel that love
absolutely
um it was actually more pressure I've
ever felt in my life you know really
yeah when so many people are behind you
you know you don't want to let anyone
down but it was also the most
exhilarating feeling and I feel like I'm
still floating on that energy and you
know I I hope to go back and and feel
that again and see other players go
through that you know I don't I don't
want to butcher the quote but I saw that
you said something to the effect of this
was a step and there will be a next step
so does that mean that you and
professional tennis are still very much
going Full Throttle you know I still
spend a lot of time on the course so you
know we'll see where that takes me and
you know just to watch your sister in
this beautiful Evolution that she's
going through right now what do you make
of all of that she's created everything
she does she's still the best player
play right now she could be number one
if she so desired so it's incredible to
see the way she walked away from the
game still the best and you know it just
shows that the whole world's ready for
her when you think about Venus Williams
and the Venus Williams Brand what does
this next chapter of life look like for
you honestly I want to spend this time
just helping others I love mentoring on
and off of the court and I want to give
this information and knowledge that I
have here and it gives me so much joy to
do that so I think that's what I'll
focus on more than anything by the way
is this a sister weekend do you guys
have like fun plans yeah and you know my
my niece
my niece so you have very serious plans
outside of this you know Olympia really
stole the show at the U.S open seeing
the matching outfits and her cheering in
the stands I mean what is it like for
you to have like a front row seat to
that beautiful bond between Serena and
her daughter I mean I'm happy I get to
be a part of it and as an aunt you know
we only do the fun stuff so
sign me up
[Music]